you do that i hope dudes who makes it
let's do it again next time our next
assignment is to watch bloodsport again
in an effort to secure sponsorship i
have created several advertisements for
various possible brand partnerships will
sasso you will now read these
advertisements in the astonishing voice
of jesse ventura
this is jesse ventura ed reads began
all right uh good times this is the
jesse ventura ad reads right
uh yeah i guess we'll just that's right
here we go
wrong thing
papi uh okay papias proud
okay
all right
i held my breath underwater for
i fought bob backlund when i just got in
minnesota
but i'm the governor of minnesota get
into it
papias proud to present the new
pinkaholic nut line
papia is proud to present the new
pinkaholic line of harnesses and
accessories for the dog in your life
whether you have a teacup yorkie spaniel
or a brontosaurus sized pit mastiff who
puts your bowel movements to shame
your pooch deserves to be slathered in
pink so fabulous you'll want to wear it
yourself pinkaholic get in the zone
well let me tell you about the color
pink in 1975
the cia began experimenting with various
pigments made from rare materials
harvested from around the globe at great
taxpayer expense
in an attempt to produce a pink tone
that could absorb all light effectively
becoming invisible
they called it null pink and
they called it
they called it null pink and they
produced 47 gallons of it
then they shipped it from a lab in the
u.s
navy headquarters they shipped it
from the lab to the new
they shipped it from the lab to the us
navy headquarters in washington
but the shipment never arrived the cia
scuttled the project and those gallons
of null pink were never recovered at
least not in the official log
so unless your dog is wearing an
invisible collar i don't really give a
[ __ ] what kind of pink it's wearing
all right all right that's uh
is that i don't think no pink is a i've
never heard of that have you no i don't
know what null pink is that sounds like
that sounds like a thing
well it's a jesse ventura thing so who
knows well doozy
found it somewhere
um do you think we'll get uh perhaps a
sponsorship from uh puppy i know that
lulio has a puppy a harness does he
really he does you're already a puppy a
customer he's a puppy a pup
most cold brew can be overpriced and
quite frankly not that tasty
that's why two roommates andrew and alex
brewed up an idea to start their old
their own cold brew company and they
called it busy organic cold brew in
their cramped apartment in
2013
and for the past nine years they've
strived to make their coffee better
every day and now they're proud to
present busy organic breakfast blend
coffee brew
busy coffee for busy people
get busy with it
busy is as busy does
the busier the bee
the sweeter the busy coffee
being busy is our business
busy bossy d biz with busy
busy organic cold brews deliciously
roasted cold brew coffee
brewed for 18 hours to yield the perfect
extraction
well let me tell you about the perfect
extraction
osama bin laden wasn't just killed by
seal team six
there were five other teams
but what happened to team what to teams
one through five how did they get out
why do we never hear about them
it's because they were coded in no
it's because they were coated in no pink
completely invisible and the cia has
been placing null pink operatives in
every
in every crisis center around the globe
for the last 50 years
there are invisible specters walking
amongst us next time you feel that
tingling sensation
like someone's in the room with you it's
because they are
no pinks are notorious for silently
watching civilians while they eat and
sleep
the next sip of busy cold brew you take
may be your last
jesus christ all right pretty good
usda choice
usda choice trim tri-tip roast is on
sale at ralph's
uh
mouth-watering tri-tip is only 4.99 a
pound with your ralph's club card
ralph's we're your usda choice trim
tri-tip headquarters
ralph's you've died and gone to usda
choice trim tri-tip heaven
ralph's the usda choice trimmed tri-tip
it's what's for dinner
ralph's
let me give you a tip
a usda choice trimmed tri-tip
here we go well let me tell you about
choices or should i say lack thereof
some of the null pinks had families who
also had to become null pinks
it was
it was too much of a risk to have wives
and children snooping around so the cia
indoctrinated them as operatives too and
now anytime a null pink is born they're
born into active operative st operative
status there are null pink babies spying
on babies of various us political
adversaries around the globe as we speak
so the next time you hear someone
casually say
oh he or she is as innocent as a baby
ask that person what kind of baby
they're referring to
because if it's a no pink baby it's not
innocent
the next usda choice trim tri-tip you
eat may be your last
uh
no matter what
no matter what kind of plug and play spa
you have in mind aqua rest has you
covered
whether it's the premium 154 four-person
plug-and-play with 12 stainless jets
ozone and led waterfall or the premium
600 six-person plug-and-play
with 29 stainless jets ozone and led
waterfall or even the daydream 4500
six person 45 jet plug and play hot tub
with waterfall we're your one stop shop
for multi-jet four to six person
plug-and-play spas
well let me tell you about one-stop
shops in the mid-1990s an xcia agent who
worked on the null pink project began
selling certain items he'd acquired over
time to the highest bidders
all done discreetly in the highest
channels of power in the world of course
right now there are several celebrities
in possession of various
quantities of null pink
sarah jessica parker has five ounces
timothy chalamet has a pint
lebron james has some
pete davidson jason momoa
kim karns
danny devito
megan the stallion
kathy lee gifford cristiano ronaldo
little nozzex the leader of def leppard
the lead singer of def leppard
albert buholz and the list goes on and
on so what are these celebrities doing
with their null pink
no one has any idea except for the null
pinks themselves watching every move
so get a plug and play spa and pretend
that paul giamatti isn't throwing an
invisible sex party in the hollywood
hills on the last thursday of every
month
paul giamatti has the ability to turn
people invisible and he's using it to
have invisible sex parties
it makes sense
billabong's air light engineered
performance board shorts are made with
award-winning air light technology that
brings three engineered fabrics together
giving you flexibility stability and
comfort where you need it most
billabong
life's veteran board shorts
billabong
billabong life's better in board shorts
billabong
building buildings all day long
billabong
billadong billabong biladong
billabong
billabillabilla
[Applause]
[Laughter]
well let me tell you about a bong tommy
chong was sentenced to nine months in a
federal prison in 2003 for selling a
water bong many people thought this
sentence was too harsh but what most
people don't know
is that it would have been much worse if
the drug enforcement agency had found
the other drug paraphernalia he was
selling but chong coated it in no pink
and it was undetectable
and now somewhere there's a landfill
with two tons of tommy chong's invisible
bongs just waiting for someone to dig
them up
if billabong really wants to sell board
shorts they should be running a contest
whoever buys the most board shorts gets
to be the subject of a six-part doctor
series called
the six part docu series called finding
tommy chong's invisible bongs in
billabongs
thank you for your service
oh my god dude
i'm [ __ ] sweating
from that oh just don't drink
dude i've never heard of that that's not
a thing no that's not a thing i i'd
never heard of it but i figured it was a
thing and after we got through them i
realized
they don't really use that as a thing
moving on
please tell a friend
here's what you do
please tell a friend then break a
preview
if you like dudes here's what you do
[Music]
please and then